AND DANA PERINO AND THIS IS "THE
FIVE."
>> NORTH KOREA BEST WANT MAKE
ANYMORE THREATS TO THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY WILL BE MET WITH FIRE AND
FURY AND POWER THE LIKES OF
WHICH THIS WORLD HAS NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
IT'S TIME SOMEONE STOOD UP FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
IF ANYTHING HAPPENS TO GUAM
THERE WILL BE BIG, BIG TROUBLE.
>> ROCKET MAN IS ON A SUICIDE
MISSION FOR HIMSELF AND FOR HIS
REGIME.
>> CRITICS CLAIM THE PRESIDENT'S
RHETORIC ON NORTH KOREA COULD
LEAD US TO WAR.
BOY, WERE THEY AS SHOCKED BY THE
BREAK THROUGH THAT NO ONE SAW
COMING.
THE PROSPECT OF A PEACEFUL
RESOLUTION TO THE NUCLEAR
STANDOFF.
KIM JONG-UN IS WILLING TO MEET
IN PERSON WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR TALKS.
THIS IS A STUNNING DEVELOPMENT.
HERE'S MORE FROM SECRETARY OF
STATE REX TILLERSON.
>> THIS WAS THE MOST FORWARD
LEANING REPORT IN TERMS OF KIM
JONG-UN'S NOT JUST WILLINGNESS
WHAT CHANGED WAS HIS POSTURE IN
A DRAMATIC WAY THAT CAME AS A
SURPRISE TO US AS WELL.
THAT HE WAS SO FORWARD LEANING
IN HIS CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DELEGATION FROM SOUTH KOREA.
>> IT WILL TAKE SEVERAL WEEKS TO
AGREE ON TIMING AND LOCATION OF
THE TALKS, BUT THE PRESIDENT
SAID IT WILL HAPPEN BY MAY.
HE IS WINNING SOME UNUSUAL
PRAISE FROM CRITICS, BUT THERE
IS SKEPTICISM ABOUT THE UPCOMING
SIT DOWN.
WHY HAS NO SITTING AMERICAN
PRESIDENT EVER MET WITH A LEADER
FROM NORTH KOREA?
WHY HAS THAT NEVER HAPPENED?
WHY HASN'T ANY OTHER PRESIDENT
DONE THIS?
SHOULDN'T I TAKE THAT TO MEAN
THIS MIGHT BE A RISKY OR UNWISE
MOVE?
>> THERE IS A BETTER CHANCE THAT
A MEETING BETWEEN KIM JONG-UN
AND DONALD TRUMP COULD BE
SUCCESSFUL.
>> THIS IS A BREAK THROUGH IF HE
PLAY WITH RIGHT.
>> KIM JONG-UN IS GETTING
SOMETHING THAT HIS FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER WANTED.
THE OPTICES OF SITTING DOWN AT
THE TABLE AS EQUALS FACE-TO-FACE
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IN THIS CASE DONALD TRUMP.
>> DANA PERINO, DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS GETTING APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATION FOR THE STEPS HE
HAS TAKEN THAT RESULTED IN THIS?
>> I THINK SO.
HE IS GETTING A NET PLUS IN
TERMS OF COVERAGE.
A LITTLE DOSE OF SKEPTICISM.
NOT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT BUT
ABOUT KIM JONG-UN.
APPROPRIATELY SO.
IN 1996 AND 2005 THEY TRIED THE
SAME THING.
NOT FACE-TO-FACE TALKS BUT TALKS
IN EXCHANGE FOR SOMETHING.
IN THIS CASE IT SEEMS THAT
DEPENDING ON WHAT KIM JONG-UN
DOES, THEY MIGHT GET NOTHING FOR
IT.
THEY WANT THE TALKS FOR WHAT?
HE SAID HE WON'T DO ANY MISSILE
TESTS BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN THIS
MEETING TAKES PLACE.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD OTHER THINGS
AS TO WHAT KIM JONG-UN WANTS.
IT'S A DIFFERENT SITUATION NOW
BECAUSE HE HAS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
NOW.
HE COMES TO THE TABLE IN A
DIFFERENT POSITION.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S STANCE AND HIS
WILLINGNESS TO BE REALLY
TOUGH -- PLUS, THERE IS THIS
THING THAT KIM JONG-UN WAS
WORRIED HE WOULD BECOME SADDAM
HUSSEIN.
THERE IS A REASON KADAFI TURNED
OVER HIS NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
IS PRESIDENT TRUMP GETTING
ENOUGH CREDIT?
I THINK SO.
ALSO HE CAN'T WORRY ABOUT THAT
TOO MUCH.
LOOKING BACK THIS COULD BE VERY
POPULAR.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN HE SAID "FIRE
AND FURY" LAST SPRING AND THERE
WAS A HUGE FIRE FIGHT ABOUT THAT
IN THE MEDIA.
MY GOSH, HE WILL LEAD US TO
NUCLEAR WAR.
LOOKING BACK AND EACH IN "VANITY
FAIR" AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES,"
SEVERAL PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT
ACTUALLY WORKED IN GETTING TO
THIS POINT.
ON BALANCE HE IS GETTING CREDIT
IF THAT'S WHAT THE GOAL IS.
THE GOAL SHOULD NOT BE CREDIT.
IT'S THE OUTCOME
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH KOREA.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
NEVERTHELESS, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TIME FRAME HERE CONGRESSMAN,
THIS IS A QUICK TURN ABOUT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMING IN AND
BEING ABLE TO ACHIEVE THIS
DIPLOMATIC ACCORD TO SIT DOWN
WITH HIM.
>> IT REMINDS ME OF WHAT REAGAN
DID.
TOOK A DOCTRINE OF PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
DONALD TRUMP LAID DOWN THE LINE
EARLY AND WOULD DO WHAT IT TOOK
TO PROTECT THE UNITED STATES AND
PROTECT GUAM AND THE ALLIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
I THINK THAT'S PAYING OFF IN
GREAT DIVIDENDS.
IT DID HAPPEN QUICKLY.
IF THEY DELAY THE TIMELINE -- WE
NEED TO LET THIS PLAY OUT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT US IN A
POSITION WHERE WE CAN PREVAIL
AND MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER AND
SAFER PLACE.
>> IF THEY DEMOLISHED MOUNT
RUSHMOORE AND PUT 4 OBAMA HEADS
RIGHT.
THERE THE POINT ABOUT THE
OPTICES.
KIM IS GETTING SOMETHING FOR
NOTHING.
IT MAY HELP ROCKET MAN.
BUT, WHY WOULDN'T HE DO IT?
THAT'S GOING TO BE PART OF THE
DEAL.
IT WILL PROBABLY HELP HIM
SURVIVE.
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO SUCCEED, WE
HAVE TO BE SUPER-SKEPTICAL AND
MAKE SURE THERE IS RESTITUTION
FOR OTTO WARMBIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPENT TIME WITH
HIS DAD.
I AM SURE THAT WILL BE PART OF
THE DEAL.
WHAT HAPPENED TO OTTO WARMBIER?
WHO WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
HORRIBLE TREATMENT AND PUNISH
THEM.
THAT'S AS BIG TO ME PERSONALLY
AS MAKING SURE THERE ARE
INSPECTORS THERE TO LOOK AT
THEIR NUKES.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE PART OF.
IT YOU CAN'T LET HIM GET AWAY
WITH THAT.
OBVIOUSLY THE SANCTIONS WORKED.
THE SANCTIONS WORKED BECAUSE I
WOULD CALL THE SANCTIONS THE
TRUMP HANDSHAKE.
IT DOESN'T LET GO AND GETS
TIGHTER AND TIGHTER.
IT CAN GO ON FOREVER.
HE TARGETED COUNTRIES.
I AM CENTICAL BUT I WILL --
CENTICAL BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
-- SKEPTICAL BUT I WILL SAY
THIS.
IT'S AN INTERESTING CONTRAST
BETWEEN REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS ARE LIKE THE SINGLE
PARENT.
REPUBLICANS ARE LIKE BOTH
PARENTS.
YOU HAVE THE CARROT AND THE
STICK.
DEMOCRATS THINK ALL THEY HAVE TO
DO IS YELL WORLD PEACE AND IT
WILL HAPPEN.
NO, YOU NEED A CARROT AND A
STICK.
I THINK TRUMP HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD AT WEILDING THAT STICK.
>> JUAN?
>> I HEARD RHETORIC THAT WAS
THREATENING AND HOSTILE AND MADE
PEOPLE FEAR THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
MIGHT DO A STRIKE AGAINST NORTH
KOREA.
I DON'T THINK IT LED TO THIS.
WHAT I THINK WHAT LED TO THIS
WAS THE SOUTH KOREA PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY TAKING THE RISK OF
COMING TOGETHER AND SAYING WE
WANT TO REUNIFY AND BE ONE.
WHY DON'T YOU NORTH KOREANS JOIN
US AT THE OLYMPIC AND HAVE
TALKS.
TALKS WITH VICE-PRESIDENT PENCE
BROKE DOWN.
BUT THE SOUTH KOREA PRESIDENT
DID MEET.
TODAY REX TILLERSON THE
SECRETARY OF STATE SAID IT'S A
SURPRISE TO US SPEAKING OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THAT YOU
GET KIM CHANGING HIS POSTURE IN
THIS WAY.
TODAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
SARAH SANDERS WAS UNSURE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE HE IS GOING
TO AS A PRE-CONDITION TO ANY
TALKS DENUKE FIRST.
SARAH SANDERS MADE IT SEEM LIKE
WE ARE NOT SURE ABOUT THIS.
TILLERSON SAID SITTING DOWN TO
TALK IS NOT NEGOTIATION.
A BIG WIN FOR TRUMP OR NOT, IS
HE GETTING ENOUGH CREDIT OR NOT?
I THINK THE REAL ISSUE IS:
HOW DO WE DEAL AS A COUNTRY WITH
NORTH KOREA?
ARE WE DOING SO EFFECTIVELY?
>> SOUTH KOREAS SAID IT WAS THE
PRESENCE OF DONALD TRUMP THAT
LED TO THIS.
>> IF YOU GO BACK TO REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS, EVEN LIKE TO
BUSH AND CLINTON AND OBAMA, ALL
OF THEM TRIED TO MAKE A DEAL.
IT'S NOT THEIR FAILING.
I THINK IT'S THE FAILING OF THE
NORTH KOREA REGIME TO HOLD TO
THEIR WORD.
THEIR WORD WAS WITH 6-PARTY
TALKS.
THEY ALWAYS LIED.
>> YOU NAILED IT BY MENTIONS ALL
OF THE PAST PRESIDENTS.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
WE ARE THE CRAZY PERSON ON THE
STREET FOR ONCE.
THAT IS WORKING.
HE IS UNPREDICTABLE.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WILL DO
AND UNPREDICTABILITY IS A GREAT
CARD TO HAVE IN YOUR HAND.
NORTH KOREA WAS FACING SOMEBODY
WHO MIGHT ACTUALLY NUKE YOU.
THAT'S A FIRST.
THEY DIDN'T EXPECT ANYBODY ELSE
TO DO THAT.
THIS GUY MIGHT DO IT.
THE WAY THE SANCTIONS ARE GOING,
THIS GUY -- IT WON'T END WELL
FOR US AND IT MAY STILL NOT END
WELL FOR KIM.
I AM WORRIED ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
NORTH KOREA.
WE STILL HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT.
IF THEY ARE STILL STARVING.